talk so it's my pleasure to introduce
vessel that Gordon will talk to us about
lattice packings and crispy glass okay
thank you for having me so I will start
with a bit of a visual introduction
before we get to the real definitions
and this topic is very nice because it's
very geometrical so let's start with the
problem square packing problem most of
you probably already know it the
question is how can we back identical
spheres in space it's that the density
or the density is maximized and as you
can see this problem is very structured
however the solutions the optimal
solutions are not so on the Left we have
the optimal solution in dimension two
also known as like the hexagonal packing
and on the right you see the optimal
solution in dimension three however we
don't know much more than that's because
only solve in dimension 2 3 18 24 18 24
hour of score of course from the g8 and
and what makes this problem art is the
lack of the structure in the problem
statement basically all we can do is we
can constrain this problem bit by
looking at so called lattice packing
backings and here we have the extra
constraint at the Centers of all these
spheres much most for my lattice and
this makes the problem significantly
easier and that's why it's already soft
up to dimension 8 and also so given a
lattice you can always create this
packing by just making these spheres
radius 1/2 times the minimum distance
between two points and if we look at
this problem as kind of an optimization
problem then our solution space is the
space of all possible letters and if we
don't care about cybertek
Asians or the QWERTY normal
transformations then one way to
represent this is as positive definite
product forms programmatic forms and in
fact these form a cone so this is kind
of every point in this space will give
you a and because we don't care too much
about scaling because given a lattice
packing if you scale everything up the
density stays the same we all now look
at only those lattice packings that have
spheres of radius at least one and what
you then get is the so-called risk of
polyhedron so all the points inside of
this protein urine correspond to let's
package with radius at least one and
everything about this this polyhedron is
infinite like you have an infinite
number of facets only even infinite
number of facets you have an infinite
number of vertices and when you have
this restriction on the on the size of
the spheres the only thing that's left
to do is to minimize the empty space
around these spheres and in fact if you
give like the function that the Monty
space then this is a concave function in
this code and so we get a concave
minimization problem over this
polyhedron and from this we know that
the optimal light versus
I just told you that we have an infinite
number first so this doesn't seem to to
help that much however most of these
shirts correspond to basically the same
that smacking and so we have some notion
of similarity that let's pack these are
basically the same and under this notion
there are only a finite number of really
non similar verses okay so let's use
this to solve the let's packing problem
in any dimension we just fix her to
mention sorry later we'll talk about how
many of them so how do we solve that
spec problem well we just enumerate all
these non similar verses I will pick the
best one and this is exactly what for
noise are random does well it does it
starts at like a single vertex and then
it finds all the neighboring verses if
the this new vertex is already like
similar to one that's already been found
before then we just discard it and if
it's a new one then we continue this
exploration and actually if this at some
point it will finish because finite
number of verses and you can also prove
that if this finishes you already a
proof that you actually have found all
of them all the just keep moving so
normally if you if it's like you're
maximizing then you can okay it's
somewhere that the solution is somewhere
in the center or something you
and I won't go too deep in like in the
next talk to Sherman we'll go a bit
deeper in how to actually run this
algorithm but I want to leave if you
like our runners in any way you're going
to be very happy with this this thing
because it involves rillettes problems
like shortage factor problems let this
asymmetry
let's reduction in the field of
computational geometry is for example
you need to solve the dual description
problem and also to make this feasible
you need to abuse a lot of symmetries
and for this you also need to do a lot
of group computations in like
permutation groups so compute
stabilizers orbits all those kind of
things so you don't know of our enemies
to actually yeah okay now we get to the
real definitions so the space we're
working is the space of real symmetric
mesas so D will always be d will always
be the dimension of these lettuces or
love like let's packings and this space
itself has a dimension and equal to 1/2
times D plus D minus 1
and this is just the amount of
coefficients on like an upper triangular
matrix like the triangular coefficients
okay now to in order to make these nice
pictures we need some kind of geometry
on this space so we define the following
inner product and it's called known as
the trace inner product but you don't
care much about it's just if you take
this matrix and you collapse it at home
it's one big factor and it's just now if
you have a symmetric matrix you can
define a quadratic form by just saying
looking at x transpose x times Q times X
times X for a factor X and the nice
thing about this inner product is that
this thing has a geometric
interpretation namely it's this value is
the same as taking the inner product
with Q and it's outer product X and as a
result if you take a fixed factor X and
you look at all chromatic forms that
take a certain fixed value on the six
then they all line one hyperplane and if
you take all credit forms that have
value at least something then you get
like a whole space
and for a positive definite credit form
so these are the ones in this cone we
saw earlier we can define some nice
properties namely the aromatic minimum
which is just the minimum value it takes
on all nonzero integer factors and what
are these factors we call them the
minimum factors we know by Minich you
okay so how does this correspond to this
let's packings well if you have a
lattice with a certain basis B then you
can construct a postal technocratic form
by just looking at the gram matrix and
what's the density of like a let's
packing given if you look at the lattice
well we can't just look locally because
it's just a repeating pattern and then
the density will be the volume of this
is ball divided by the volume of this
for annoy cell so and the first one is
proportional in some sense to this
arithmetic minimum and the second one is
proportional to and we covered the ratio
and we call this the this is known as
the hermit's invariant and this is
directly proportional to the density of
this corresponding letters so instead of
working with lettuces and that's
packings we just care about quadratic
forms and we try to maximize this its
ratio and this is known as the hermit's
constant
so now we get back to this risk of
polyhedra so for a fixed lambda we want
to only consider all the static forms
that have a grammatical million at least
lambda and this corresponds exactly to
like lattice backings where the spheres
have a and another way to describe this
is that for every nonzero entry vectors
vector these periodic forms must take
value at least lambda on them so for
every nonzero entry vector you get this
half space but it's nice you imagine
property and the risk of here is just
the intersection of all these house
spaces so important to note that every
facet of this visual polyhedron
corresponds exactly to one of these
nonzero integer vectors in a product is
defined before I mean what we use is
this yeah they take it's the same you
can everything is everything is okay so
every facet is a nonzero vector and now
the optimization problem becomes so much
easier if we restrict to this space
because you only have to minimize this
empty space around it that's left
and that's exactly given by this and by
makovski we know that this function is
concave in this cone and so deal of
optimality vs of this risk of what are
these forces well these are the ones
that we go perfect forms or perfect
lettuces and definition just to say okay
he was perfect if and only if it's
vertex of one of these risk of collision
and and note that the minimum number of
minimum vectors or such a parent form is
at least n up to
like two times M because you have person
- yes and that's the case because every
vertex is adjacent to at least n which
the dimension of the space facets and
these are exactly also the minimum
vectors of this perfect form
lies at the vertex
okay now quick note about the
similarities go if you have a letter
basis B and you have a basis B times so
genome all are you so it's just based
transformation then we know that they
generates the same lines and we can do
something similar for credit forms but
then you get this new transpose Q yeah
so yeah like if X is a short factor
sorry minimal vector than minus X is
also but X and minus X give the same
facet the same X transpose is the same
for plus or minus 6
yeah
and what's nice to know is that these
like aromatic minimum and determinant
are what he would expect like they stay
the same under this transformation and
we want the slightly broader notion of
similarity because we don't care about
scale okay so now a nice question would
be like how many of these performs or
how many of these non similar versus do
we have so if you would start running
this algorithm have any sense of how
complex is already miss at least you
would want to know how many of these
things you have to know right so what do
we know well we only know all the the
perfect forms up to dimension eight for
example in dimension two which is the
one I showed all these pictures for
because then the mention to the NH three
which is and we have you see that we
have only one non similar perform so
actually all these purchases you saw
before are the same or they are the same
of two basis transformation but if we go
up in the mansion we see that at some
points the among them quickly increases
so only in 2005 and and fun volunteen
they succeeded the numeration dimension
eight and thereby also proving laps
packing theorem but it was already
proven before and in the mention nine
they found more than half a million of
these and they're my master's thesis i
also try to improve the tolerance a bit
and more than 23 million but still with
no end in sight like way way more the
optimal solution dimension a it was
already known
that was being done to try to find the
solution we already think to know the
optimal solution like the thing is you
during this enumeration you find the
optimal solution pretty quickly for a
lot of reasons but you need to finish
this whole enumeration to know for sure
that you haven't missed any there are
ways to like you can instead of doing
the full enumeration you can do like a
random walk on this graph and then you
also find pretty good you can start I
mean the depend you need to solve like
let's say sama tree and also or that's
not the person that you do green walk
that's shortage factor problems and then
you need to do this dual description I
think if you can solve the short factor
problem quickly you can run this in 24
but you can't run this in 24 no problem
but you're not going to be able to so
what do we know in terms of how many of
these things we have so let's call PD
the number of these synaptic losses then
the known bounds okay so in 1998
Christoph's relay proves an upper bounds
exponential and D to the fourth lovely
and he used is also to say some nice
things about the fan defy conjecture in
the theory and pretty recently Roland
better gave a constructive lower bound
exponentially an exponential adopts
Englishman
and an upper-bound exponential d cube
lotty and in this talk we will give a
nice pneumatic proof of that gives an
upper bound actually I show in this is
like I don't know a matrix of T squared
entries of size so the space is already
like of size d squared so this this this
could well be tied already in for
example paper bullying bats for you
already gave a little like your stick
reasons why this should be the upper
bound and also if you see this this list
and very small sample size but it makes
it's more than extra extra netting
legend anchovies you would say okay so
what's the ID well suppose you have a
cone and inside of this cone you have a
polyhedron then at each vertex you can
create the so-called outer normal cone
which is just for every facet you have
the normal and you take the cone
generated by these normal factors and
note that if you have two of these
virtues that are next to each other then
these outer normal cones fit nicely
together so why we just do we create all
these out normal cones we grab them
together and that's what you get on the
right and then we just
and what you see is that this polyhedron
gives in some sense a subdivision of of
this color on the right and we have a
bit a little bit of space left here but
that's just for any vertex set yet and
we can do exactly the same with our risk
of polyhedron so every like let's say we
have this vertex then you have the the
the three facets around it each them
guess a normal which corresponds to
these minimum factors and then you take
this this stone and we look at all these
cones from from above first grab them
together and then for example this
vertex corresponds to cone and this for
this corresponds to this one
okay what are these scones exactly these
outer normal Congress dessert so called
for in our domains which are just if you
take a positive infinity form and you
take this many minimum factors and you
look at like XX transpose of these
mineral factors and you just take the
cone that's spent by these things and
these are this cone is only fill
dimensional if and only if Q is perfect
which makes sense because you only get
the four dimensional outer cone at at
first just like the facet or an edge you
don't get an L dimensional and I quickly
want to go back to this picture because
this is exactly the picture that's kind
of gave me the ID for for the proof
actually the same picture is in the the
book pass you Sherman about this topic
and so what we see is we have all these
four narrow domains however it's clear
that we can't fit many of these some of
them are large and we can't fit many of
these large ones inside of but in the
mention too is also saw that actually
all of these foreigner domains
correspond to the same lattice packing
up to like this basic transformation so
what if we can in every similarity class
we can find at least one representative
that has a song with large
representative large foreigner domain if
we do that then we can come have that
many similarity class
okay so this in more concrete terms this
we have an upper bound on like the size
of this cone and we want to find a
complete set of representatives such
that these foreigner domains are lower
bound is in some sense foreigner domain
yeah so yeah so I will quantify this but
in some sense they would say okay the if
you have this everyone this lower bound
then the number of classes can be
divided by two and of course we need to
like this discount are infinite so just
talk about for you so for this we just
put a cap on them so we restrict
yourself to the following half space
which is just we bound to trace by one
which is nothing more than just this
flat cap and if you do that then we
don't have to worry about the volume of
these cards okay so very quickly what's
the volume or the simplex well you can
just in n-dimensional in n dimensions
and one over n factorial times the
determinant of all the pairwise like the
gram matrix of all these spending
okay so it is foreigner domains they are
spent by these these minimum factors
these xx transpose but we have put a cap
on them so we need to normalize by the
trace and the trace exactly X transpose
X so what we don't get is these simple
says they they don't necessarily have to
be synthesized but we can try to lower
about the volume so we can assume that
they are yeah so these are just the
normalized race given by this
now we can just compute the volume
that's that's art so you get this maybe
what you can do is you can just take
these normalization factors out of them
so we get this product of the
normalization factors in front now all
these these these factors are integer
and such as a result these inner
products are also in insert and so we
have a determinant of in geometric
metrics and we know it's nonzero because
these things are four-dimensional so
they come as volume 0 and so this has to
be at least 1 and so we remain with this
thing and we want to find some set of
representatives such as this is always
and we immediately see that for this we
have two upper bounds the size of these
minimal factors and that's where the
following slightly technical lemma comes
in I won't give the proof and this lemma
just says ok we can find such a complete
set of Representatives for which these
minimal factors are of polynomial size
in the dimension and for proof this
Jesus transference theorems and and you
know that's reduction about the size of
the coordinates you can have some basis
those polynomial the polynomial
coordinates
okay and I mean now we can just plug
this in and we get that the volume is
this thing well and then we are
basically done number of these
similarity clusters mostly upper bound 5
lower bound all the upper bounds we
didn't need to care about small and the
lower bound if you write that you got
this and now remind yourself that this n
is prolific in the dimension so because
of this n factorial and this and in the
exponent you get exactly this
[Applause]
so you can restrict your search patient
do you have any ideas for lower Bell
like a better lower I mean higher you
have to do some constructs as proof but
that's direct IDs for that if you want
to turn something like this and in a
lower bound then are a bit of problems
like you for example at some point you
just assume okay assume this is like a
sub cone that's the simplex but of
course this thing can be much larger and
also now we only need to find like one
big representives
but if you go for a lower bound then you
kind of need to know the size of all all
foreigners domains that correspond to
one class so you might be able to say
something about I mean you know that
they love them at some point they have
to decrease because otherwise they can
never fit in this cone expression
yeah describe system
my question is kind of similar you sent
through the heuristic same boundaries I
mean in global sense it's just like the
space the solution space is of size D
square so it wouldn't be like in that
sense it's not too surprising that you
get something extra nancial in in the
solution space you're working in that's
of course like no real argument the
other your stick is just we find a lot
of them so it's yeah now if you I think
if you in the I did this a few years ago
so it's I think in the paper of Rowland
batcher
it's all my favorite roll investor I
think I could try to get some rear 6y
why you need it or like also and here's
there now you might be able to know know
collect so with with this proof not I
mean it's this n factorial which already
gives you the it already gives you this
local next one might be some way to get
rid of I don't find it very where
together
but there are no more questions I think
[Applause]